[Music]
Assassin's Creed Odyssey greatly expands
upon the RPG stylings of its predecessor
not only as the game's world much bigger
but there's a wealth of new mechanics
and systems in place to play with
dialogue choices give you more freedom
to guide the direction of your journey
in subtle yet meaningful ways a
territory system has you aligning
yourself with the competing powers of
the Peloponnesian War to carve out the
land and this is in addition to the
variety of improvements that have been
made to pre-existing systems from
origins if you're returning origins
player or a newcomer entirely a lot of
the new features and mechanics may
perplex you to help give you more
clarity overall the new systems in
Odyssey we've gathered 11 tips that
should help you become the best Spartan
mercenary / proto assassin you can be
[Music]
this isn't so much a tip as a strong
recommendation one of the most
meaningful features added into odyssey
is exploration mode a navigation option
that strips away markers and quest
objectives forcing you to rely on your
investigative and observation skills
instead the mode offers a more
challenging experience that's well worth
the effort Assassin's Creed Odyssey has
some great side quests that offer
stories that range from tense and
serious to funny and light-hearted if
you can scrotum and a deep tongue oh is
that all you need some even tie back
into the main narrative with so much
content in Odyssey you might be
wondering which side quests are worth
your time you'll find two types of
quests in the world first our quests
indicated on the map by these gold and
black diamonds these are the major side
quests that are the most involved and in
our experience are always worth your
time the other kinds of quests are much
smaller usually consisting of a simple
task you can find these on the map with
white and black diamond markers or at
the message slash bounty boards the
quality of these quests vary with some
fun small objectives like defending a
philosopher and others being noticeably
lame like this one where you just need
to walk a couple of hundred meters and
talk to an NPC to complete it if you're
the kind of person who isn't interested
in doing everything possible and just
wants to see the good stuff we recommend
avoiding these smaller quests completely
and only doing the major side quests
with the gold and black markers
[Music]
weapons and armor play an even greater
role in Odyssey allowing you to
customize your look there are several
ways to get awesome new gear completing
major side quests is a pretty
straightforward option and the quest
menu even shows what reward you will
earn mercenaries are another great way
to earn loot you can check the
mercenaries menu to see a detailed
description of the loot each has and
then track the one you want to find this
is the most reliable way to search for
something specific there are also
conquest battles which rewards you with
a random piece of epic loot if you find
a piece of armor that has stats you like
or just looks cool you can always
upgrade it at a blacksmith bringing it
up to your current level this is an
awesome way to ensure legendary gear you
get early on remains viable in the late
game you can even enhance gear further
with engravings which give you bonuses
like increased damage against certain
enemy types or boosts the specific
abilities
the best way to find engravings are from
the puzzle tablets that contain riddles
on them similar to origins is papyrus
puzzles following the clues to the
treasure rewards you with the new
engraving engravings can then be
upgraded by completing an associated
goal or challenge so keep an eye on
those to maximize the potential
engravings aren't just one-time use
items either so don't worry about saving
one for later and just put it on you can
also swap engravings whenever you want
but it will cost you a small fee if
you're the sort of person who likes to
pick up everything that comes your way
you're liable to start stockpiling
weapons and armor really quickly don't
hold on to that stuff make sure to break
it down for resources in the inventory
menu or to visit merchants to sell them
for a reasonable profit you never want
to be hoarding items as you'll need the
money and resources from selling or
dismantling to better your current
loadout and ship
you'll also accumulate a bunch of items
that serve no purpose other than to be
sold at a shop make sure to offload
these under the option of sell all trade
goods in the sell menu
unlike origins Odyssey allows you to
acquire and swap abilities if you're
looking for some suggestions we've got
them shield enemies can be a real pain
in a large fight so pick up shield
breaker which lets you rip their shields
off and hit them with it for damage if
you want to take care of captains or
enemies with large health bars quickly
get hero strike which uses the damage
statistic normally used for assassin
attacks if you prefer the stealthy
approach though rush assassination lets
you break the laws of physics by
throwing your spear and then basically
teleporting next year targets you can
also change the seat ACK making it a
handy way to take out a base in a quiet
and efficient manner
critical assassination is also key as it
lets you deal more damage allowing you
to assassinate high-level enemies
finally you should get the Spartan kick
which is perfect for knocking enemies
off cliffs or walls and is also just
really fun
[Music]
this has been quite over the bush being
able to respect at any time is a useful
new feature that lets you experiment
with different character builds so if at
any moment you think you've dumped too
many points into one category over
another simply hold down the left stick
in the skills menu to reallocate all the
points you've earned thus far collecting
resources and materials is a major
component of Odyssey you need them to
upgrade your equipment and ship
thankfully it's not much of a headache
to collect these resources for starters
you always want to dismantle unused
equipment for materials you also have
the option to sell equipment to vendors
but the resources are much more valuable
than the money which you'll still earn
in other ways you'll find common
resources like wood and forests and iron
and caves but if you really need more
vendors will also sell them a hot tip is
to always loot war supplies before you
burn them in an enemy camp
these carry large quantities of
materials and you don't want to miss out
on them as a mercenary you are soldier
for hire in the war between Sparta and
Athens and can use this to your
advantage every region is controlled by
one of the two factions they'll first
need to lower the occupying nations grip
by burning war supplies pillaging nation
chests killing their soldiers and
assassinating their leader
once you've lowered the meter enough a
conquest battle becomes available you
can then fight for either side by
visiting their camp yes you can side
with the army who supplies you just
spent the last few hours burning down I
guess they're a forgiving bush siding
with a defending army presents you one
piece of epic gear while siding with the
invading army Nets you two pieces of
epic gear but the battle will be tougher
in our experience it's always worth
deciding with the invading army for that
extra loot when participating in the
battle itself always keep an eye out on
the two beaters up top and make sure
you're staying ahead it's best to ignore
the basic soldiers and focus on the
captains and hero units who show up
since eliminating them is the quickest
way to win because of how easily
multiple soldiers can overwhelm you it's
a good idea to pick abilities that deal
damage to multiple enemies at once such
as reign of destruction our final tip is
not to wait too long to
the conquest battle once it's available
as the opportunity can be lost if you
wait too long
thankfully you can repeat this process
in a region as many times as you want
keeping the war going forever and your
inventory filled with loot if you're a
traditional Assassin's Creed player
chances are you might not notice that
there are manual and quick save options
in Odyssey given the more pivotal
choices you'll make as the game
progresses you may want to backpedal a
few times fortunately the game is not
too brutal when it comes to auto-saves
but make sure to utilize this feature in
order to give yourself a proper backup
plan when events go south on account of
a horrible decision you made like
origins you can advance time of day by
simply holding the map button previously
this was an ability you had to acquire
via the skill tree but you're given it
early on this time around without having
to spend a skill point though the game
doesn't make a big show of it so you
might not even notice it's there
regardless advancing time is handy when
you want to attack camps at night since
the majority of guards tend to sleep
around that time making it easier for
you to sneak about and that's all the
tips to get you started an assassin's
creed Odyssey make sure to check out our
full review and all of our other
Assassin's Creed features and have
yourself a good day
[Music]